well it thanks
all of you for coming today
we're talking about sexual harassment uh
sexual violence against women you all
are not immune to it i'm not immune to
it um
and i wanted to kick off with the
abduction rape and murder of sarah
everard this year because it seemed to
me
that it lit a touch paper and what i
wanted to start off with really was for
all of you
what did that make you reflect on and
i'll start with you jess what did it
make you reflect on
about your life your experiences my
first reflection was how it felt
different in the country for staff it
felt like
for the first time women were
saying this has happened to me because
of men's behavior and it's not on me
anymore to do anything about it i mean
it made me reflect on the fact that
this is a universal experience that not
enough
has ever been done about and women have
expected been expected for too long to
just take the burden of it it made me
feel really angry
that the initial response that we were
getting was well why was she walking
alone why was she walking after dark
shouldn't she have been with someone and
yet again it's this burden of you as the
woman have to take the precautions so
that you are not the victim of male
violence and that's what really angers
me is that we still
aren't addressing in my view adequately
what are the cultures underpinning this
what makes a man think it is okay to
indecently expose himself what makes him
think it's okay to to follow a woman
home to catcall in the street and and
are these the sort of um gateway
behaviors that lead to much more
horrific crimes yeah you just think
how have we not have we not fixed this
yet how have we not kind of in brought
about the change that's needed to stop
these things happening because it was
just so
horribly depressing that still you know
still these things are happening and
still you know so we haven't made
progress i have two little girls that
sense of pure panic that what had become
so normal for me and my friends
was the world that they were growing
into do you feel that you have to try
and do something now to stop this
happening to your daughters or do you
actually think that it's inevitable that
they are going to get harassment i
signed them up to muay thai classes
that week because i thought the only way
i can protect them as their mum
is to help them learn how to defend
themselves that was how bleak i felt
about their future as they get older i
will start to have the conversations
about what they do when they walk home i
will be that parent that goes and meets
them at the train station or make sure
that i'm hiding somewhere in a car
because that's how i feel but i also i
also see the sharp end when i work in a
e and i do night shifts and i see those
girls coming in
and it's not nice and it's not okay and
they are there are teenage girls
carrying the cubicle all together
because something bad has happened to
one of them fate you were flashed at
what when you were 17 years old yeah
17-18 yeah and what was how did that
make you feel
it happened as i was walking towards the
restaurant to pick my dad up and then i
saw my dad straight away and i i
couldn't i couldn't talk to him about it
we just drove home and i tell him i did
later but i was really nervous about
telling him like i don't know why i just
felt so ashamed just really like did i
do something did i
did i bring that on i mean
what was i did i cause that and and i
just didn't know how to tell my dad that
that had happened to me because i i felt
responsible for it you had a similar
experience to that when you were
quite a young girl not flashed but i can
remember being on a school trip to
london zoo and walking uh through the
zoo and a group of and i'm going to say
men but my memory doesn't really tell me
how old they were they weren't in school
uniform or anything we were all in
school uniform uh just grabbed hold of
him and groped me and the thing
lasted no more than
two three seconds
and yet you know i was 11 years old that
lives with me to this day that
men felt empowered to literally grab a
school child as she passed especially
her hands everywhere that's it and then
gone i mean i can't remember the amount
of times i've been sexually assaulted in
my life in one way or another i remember
somebody flashing me as i was walking
into the girls school there's a park
next to the drive you had to walk up and
men would frequently just stand there
with their trousers around their ankles
people would pull up to you in cars
masturbating and like call you over to
ask you for direction so you'd go over
and they'd be masturbating this is not
something that is unusual or uncommon
i've never once called the place about
any single one of my anything that's
ever happened to me i remember having a
haircut once
a man was cutting my hair i was in my
late teens
and he had the scissors and he was doing
the front and his hands were touching my
breasts while he was cutting
my hair
and i remember thinking this is really
weird why does he need to be rubbing my
chest while he's cutting my hair
but
i didn't feel like i could say anything
i felt a bit paralysed in that moment
stuck in my own head thinking shall i
say something will
will he be offended um is this okay is
this not okay and it's only now like
decades later that i'm thinking
god almighty like that could happen
to anyone that could happen to my kids
and i'd want them to shout from the
rooftops don't touch me we talked a lot
about experiences when we were younger
women or when you were younger women but
does being an mp
and being
having a massively powerful public role
does it change it for you in one regard
it does it does stop so sexual
harassment and abuse people tend not to
grope up you only grope someone who you
can sack
oh you know i don't i don't think that's
accurate
i've had male mps stick their hands on
my backside in strangers bar i can wind
the clock back and i can remember a
really prominent man
smacking me on the back side about as
hard as he could and going oh rumsey
you've got a lovely seat
oh great um i'd have punched him in the
face
so and that's that's my that's my
problem is that who didn't
you probably johnson in the face stanley
johnson stanley johnson did that to me
ahead of the a5 election so it was
blackpool i don't know what years for
2003.
i didn't do anything and that i feel
ashamed by that no you shouldn't
that's because i am and now you probably
would now you would probably say
something let's move on
to kind of what you can do as
legislators or what you want to see more
of there's discussions in parliament
about whether or not sexual harassment
should actually become a crime do you
think the government
think that this is a priority what would
you like to see happen
the answer the simple answer is no it's
not a political priority it's not even a
priority just for the home office there
needs to be a proper offender strategy
and a proper change in how we manage
monitor
and criminalise
increasing behaviors so of the
of a hundred of the most serious and
prolific dangerous violence against
women and girls perpetrators about eight
of them but out of the 100 would
currently be being monitored the others
are freely going about abusing other
women i don't massively disagree with
with what jess was saying but the only
thing i point out is at the height of
the pandemic the government did
prioritize getting the domestic abuse
bill back into committee you all want
public sexual harassment to be a crime
yes absolutely yes make uh public sexual
harassment a specific crime that sends a
firm message it also helps you to
identify those perpetrators how can i
put this delicately early on yeah in
their offending journey yeah because we
know don't we with wayne cousins that he
flashed women before he ever kidnapped
raped and murdered sarah everard so we
it's all very well and good in the
police crime sentencing and courts bill
to focus on the serious violent serial
offenders and important that they serve
long sentences but i want to see us go
back go back and identify people at the
start is there a cultural problem at the
top of government where perhaps
politicians aren't quite getting it
i think
government
reflects where we are in society there
are some people who really get it
and really fight hard for change and
there are people who aren't there yet
but
ultimately we know that
convictions aren't where they should be
we know that prevention is not where it
should be we know that all the things
we've spoken about today mean that it
isn't safe for us and our daughters and
our friends to walk the streets
and until we crack down on the
perpetrators and until we change our
language so rather than talking about
the number of women and girls who've
experienced sexual harassment let's talk
about the number of men and boys
who are the perpetrators let's change
the language since the metoo movement we
have
moved on culturally without question
yeah to know that every single woman has
had an experience like this to know that
we know that what we haven't done
culturally
is accepted that if everybody knows a
victim
then anybody knows a perpetrator
that's much harder for people to
comprehend do you think that in the
government that some of the female
politicians leading on these strategies
get it more than
the men is that what you find inevitably
women are more engaged and more aware of
this because we've all lived with it
yeah do you feel
the fact that we're even here filming
this talking about this
do you feel more hopeful
that for
our daughters and your sons that for the
next generation this will improve
gesture yeah look i i i want to i want
to and i think young women and i have
experienced it stand up
in a way that you know every generation
i think gets a bit more like we're not
going to tolerate this
um but in my time working in it
i've never known systems and services
as degraded and as bad as they are today
and so it's quite difficult for me to
have hope about it there's too
many
women being
abused just it's too
many
and that level of volume
no government has ever been able to
handle it